they are on the run since the fall of
Tripoli three months ago Saif al-islam
the playboy Gaddafi air is now the
injured prisoner dressed in traditional
robes he was taken by his captors tues
in tan in the western mountains after
being picked up in an ambush in the
south of the country it's thought he
broken cover after attempting to reach
the border with me share this picture
shows him just after his capture covered
by a drab blanket he used to live the
most glamorous of lifestyles it's all
over now it's unclear how the injury to
his hand was sustained perhaps in an
airstrike some weeks ago or during the
capture an atomic abdali when tahini
lamba healing begins at donna shalala
announcing their prize on state
television everyone wants the glory at
the moment it could be several messy
weeks before Saif al-islam is
transferred to military commanders in
Tripoli I believe it has hasn't been
done negotiation what we believe it's
has been they've been arrested after a
raid or an operation and once we believe
that he didn't serve run batter is being
taken by surprise as word spread of the
arrest Libyans clambered to get onto the
aircraft carrying Saif al-islam they
wanted to see for themselves the famous
son who wielded real power and influence
across the country there were
celebrations at the start of the
uprising people had believed he was the
one person who could persuade his father
against violence and repression he did
not instead Saif al-islam told the
people they must fight for his father in
his words until the last bullet